Okay, so we're diving into a story today
that honestly sounds well impossible.
It's all about an NBA star's wild
comeback. And the reason behind it is
not what you'd expect. So, let's just
get right to the heart of it, right? The
big question. How does a top tier NBA
all-star, one of the best in the league,
go from playing just three games in an
entire season? I mean, that's basically
nothing to then turn around and play, 81
games the very next year. That's that's
almost a perfect season. It's the kind
of comeback that just doesn't seem real.
So, in this explainer, we're going to
unpack exactly how this happened based
on the sources for this story. All
right, first up, let's really set the
stage for this thing. We're talking
about a comeback that by all accounts
should never have happened. But, you
know, before you can get to the
comeback, you got to understand just how
bad things got. So, let's look at the
injury that was supposed to end his
career for good. Okay, so picture this.
It's 2001. Theo Ratliff is playing for
Philly and he is absolutely crushing it.
He makes the NBA All-Star team. He's at
the very top of his game, you know, the
peak of his career. And then it all just
unravels. Boom. He fractures his wrist.
Then he tears the labum in his hip. To
make things even worse, doctors find
these pre-existing degenerative
conditions. The verdict they give him,
it's brutal. They basically say, "Your
career is over. You're going to be a
lifetime project for surgeons." Can you
imagine hearing that? I mean, listen to
how Ratliff himself described it. He
said, "I was almost in the midst of
retiring. Everything was just going all
haywire. He'd hit rock bottom. The
experts, the doctors, everyone was
telling him it was over. No coming
back." But here's where the story takes
a turn. According to our sources,
someone came to him with a totally
different idea about what was going on.
And that brings us to this idea of a
mineral deficiency theory. So, what is
that? Well, the main idea from the
sources is summed up pretty well by this
quote from Ambassador Andrew Young. The
theory is basically this. The food we
eat today, because it's grown in soil
that's been overarmed, just doesn't have
the same minerals and vitamins it used
to, we're taking more out of our bodies
than we're putting back in. And this is
the perfect way to understand why,
according to this theory, athletes are
like the canary in the coal mine. Just
look at the difference. You've got an
athlete who's constantly exercising,
sweating, just burning through vital
minerals like crazy. On the other hand,
you have someone who's mostly sitting on
the couch losing minerals way, way
slower. So for the athlete, if you're
not putting those minerals back in, your
body is going to start breaking down.
It's like trying to run a race car in an
empty tank. Okay, so if the problem is a
mineral shortage, what's the fix? Well,
the sources present a specific product
as the answer. Let's check it out. The
Rebound FX solution. So this solution
they talk about is a drink called
Rebound FX. And what's interesting is
how the source material positions it
against the big guys like Gatorade and
Red Bull. You can see right here in the
comparison, way less sugar, way less
sodium, but a ton more potassium, plus a
whole bunch of vitamins that the others
just don't have. So, what exactly is in
this stuff? Well, according to the info,
the big deal is 75 different minerals
that come from plants. On top of that,
you've got a vitamin complex, B vitamins
for energy, amino acids for your
muscles, even things like green tea and
jinseng. The whole idea is to put back
everything your body burns through when
you're pushing it hard. All right, so
that's the theory and that's the
product. But here's the billiondoll
question. Did it actually work? Let's
get back to Theo Rott's story and see.
This is the proof in the performance. I
mean, just look at this timeline. It's
kind of mind-blowing. 2001 he's an NBA
all-star. The next season it's a
disaster. He plays only three games.
Career supposed to be over. Then in 2002
he starts this mineral program. And what
happens the very next year he plays 81
games. 81. And not only that, he wins
the league's shot blocking title. And
get this, after that comeback, he went
on to sign over $100 million in new
contracts. Just wow. And you don't have
to take my word for it. Here it is from
the man himself. Ratliff gives all the
credit to the guy who created the
program. He says, "Dr. Wallik helped me
expand my career 10 extra years." That's
a pretty powerful endorsement, right? A
direct line from this nutritional change
to his recovery. And you know what? It
wasn't just a one season fluke. This
wasn't some lucky break. After coming
back, he didn't just show up to play. He
dominated. He won the shot blocking
title, two years running, and even made
the alldefensive second team. He was
officially back to being an elite player
in the league. So, what's the big
takeaway from all this? Well, according
to the sources for this explainer, this
story isn't really just about one
basketball player. It's bigger than
that. So, let's zoom out a bit for our
final section. So, let's be clear about
what we're talking about when we say
mineral deficiency. According to these
sources, it's pretty simple. It's when
your body just doesn't have the
essential minerals it needs to work
right. And they point to two main
culprits that are speeding this up for
everyone. One, intense exercise, and
two, eating food that comes from soil
that's basically been stripped of all
the good stuff. And this is the key
point the sources make. This isn't just
an issue for proathletes. They argue
that this affects all of us. Whether
you're a student trying to stay focused
in class or a busy mom chasing kids
around, we're all burning through these
vital nutrients and most of the time
we're not putting them back in. And they
claim this is a root cause for a ton of
health problems. So that really leaves
us with a provocative final thought,
doesn't it? The core claim from the
sources in this story is that pretty
much all of us are running on a low
tank. That we're all mineral deficient
in some way. Which makes you wonder
what's missing from your fuel.